160 years after slavery was abolished in
the Dutch Empire the country's monarchy
has publicly acknowledged its part in
the business of slavery
King Willem Alexander said sorry for
centuries of exploitation and
commodification of hundreds and
thousands of human beings
today I stand before you today as your
king and as a member of the government I
make this apology myself and I feel the
weights of the words in my heart and my
soul
in the 1500s becoming the world's
largest transatlantic Trader it is
estimated its networks are responsible
for the trafficking of more than 600 000
people from Africa to the Americas the
king's apology met with mixed reactions
honestly I feel good but
um I am still looking forward to
something more than just apologies
reparations for example the king said
something about healing and repairing
but not necessarily about reparations
which are very important for our
community to heal for me this apology
it's in it's a justification that the
Dutch government has
seek apology for their
I don't know how they have how they call
it we will call it the crimes against
humanity the king also announced an
investigation into the Royal House of
orange Nassau's role in slavery
activists welcomed the gesture but say
there needs to be a wider conversation
about reparations the past is not the
past because we know that when slavery
was abolished the the slave owners were
they were paid compensation that is a
form of reparation and it's those same
families who have the world who have
been able to build a country but also we
know that the institutions that came
with slavery it still lives on it still
lives on in the Discrimination that
people however can listen
Alexander is the latest European leader
to openly reckon with the brutality of
colonial history in 2021 Germany agreed
to pay Namibia over a billion dollars
calling it action towards reconciliation
for the Nama Herrero genocide
Belgium's King Philippe expressed deep
regrets for the abuses committed during
the country's colonization of what is
now the Democratic Republic of Congo
the Netherlands is also establishing a
217 million dollar fund to educate its
population about the legacy of slavery
and to remind everyone it's never too
late to apologize